dolores can you kick me off with just a
welcome back scumbag
welcome back scumbag
[Laughter]
scumbag welcome back scumbag season 11
we are or in the thick of it i feel like
how are you feeling about the season so
far
don't say the thick of it yet there's a
lot of thick of it
everyone's talking behind my back i want
to leave go
it is one of the strongest seasons in a
long time before we get into all that
drama though
i want to talk about a moment that
cracked me up and i know act a lot of
people up was your reaction
to seeing margaret's boob job wow
when you saw that moment on the show
everyone's talking about that
i can't imagine that it was bad
that can't be what i was looking at i
had no idea that this is a thing
i just found out today so i have to go
back
and watch what's wrong with my reaction
well because you you're just like okay
you're like seen it let's move on
i did see it many times i've never seen
anybody naked more than margaret i
haven't seen myself naked more than i've
seen margaret naked she's got the boobs
of the young girl we went to the same
doctor
dr mark cadillac for our neck up our
face
and for the neck down we have dr joseph
michaels
okay i love good friends share these
things
very specific it's uh the neck up to the
neck
down i mean i love how open you are
about your surgeries can you give me the
full rundown of everything you've gotten
done
okay so everything i've i have from
stopped
top to bottom botox i've had
fillers i have had a facelift
i've had my boobs done several times
tummy tuck lipo
um a brazilian butt lift which means
i've had it grounded
uh and then you know recently some other
stuff that you haven't heard about yet
but stay tuned
close what's your next surgery cause you
didn't tell me about this one
david was upset about your choice to
have elective surgery
um and it's that's so weird to me
because i feel like
you going into that relationship he
knows you have a love
for this that you do what you want to do
how do you move past that almost
incompatibility thing there of him not
liking that you do these things
you know here's the one thing david
rides motorcycles
david has i think eight motorcycles
bad ass sexy motorcycles i'm not in
favor of motorcycles they scare me
i've only been on his motorcycles once
he has a love for it
but i know that's a big part of his life
me plastic surgery is not like
i'm not walking around looking like i'm
like a botched
woman but i am not aging gracefully i'm
going to tweet
and do what i want to do and that is who
i am so taking her i have to take
his love for motorcycles and he has to
take what i do
and too bad too bad you know the funny
thing is though
i always thought like he can never use
my plastic surgery
for like the excuse of well i'm not
getting engaged or i'm not going to take
it to the next level
because you do a lot of elective surgery
so you know
i waited i saw that um
i i didn't i didn't get a ring and the
and the relationship didn't go to the
next level so i said
well then i'm going to do whatever i
want to do
i would have done it eventually anyway
but i wasn't going to let that be an
excuse
i see okay you know what i'm saying yeah
no i totally get what you're saying i
want to unpack some of that
you know overall the audience doesn't
seem to get you and david there seems to
be
something that the audience is missing
about this relationship what do you
think
the viewers don't get about your
connection with him
the viewers don't get my connection with
david is
the amount of independence that we both
have from each other
and still have the relationship that we
have you have to understand we
we're at different parts of our lives
you know we're not a young couple
and um we both are very set in our ways
we both
like our space we both love our
independence
and as much as people would like me to
say oh i want more for you
i have everything i want right now and
that's a hard thing for people to grasp
because if i wanted more i would go find
it
but i i really like being with someone
who isn't so dependent on me
that if i want to get up and go away for
five days
i can just go and he's fine and he's
going to be in the same spot i loved him
[Laughter]
on this week's episode teresa makes a
joke about
if david's not going to make a move
maybe it's time to move
on ma bob bring me an amazing guy
and maybe even for dolores too because
if david doesn't make a move
we're gonna kick him to the curb you
tell him where do you see this thing
going do you
see marriage with david i don't know
so that move wasn't going to define my
relationship
at the moment i may wake up one day and
say
wow you know what maybe i really want to
get married
maybe i want to live with somebody
full-time maybe i want something
different in the relationship department
and then i'll have to weigh out if this
relationship is going to
fit me for my next part of my life
but for now it works i mean think about
it i've been divorced 22 years
that's a long time i got divorced when i
was 28 years old
i've raised my kids i've been successful
i own my own home i have so much
going for me that i don't always want to
share that with somebody and when you're
in a relationship like when you're
married when you're engaged you share so
much
more of your life and right now i'm
enjoying
and i'm living off of what i've built so
for the past 25 years my whole life
revolved around everybody but me
i want angel but i'm enjoying myself
right now
and another guy is going to be like
sitting next to me watching tv one
don't want to watch tv with you so i'm a
little afraid of
what i don't know i was only married for
a short time of my life
but i know my single life very very well
and i'm not unhappy with it you know i
think
the audience seeing frank so much also
complicates their view
of what your life should be and what
they want to project onto you because
at the end of the day you know the
viewers want to see you and frank back
together
so the viewers do want to see that but
what the viewers also have to see is
when were we ever apart a big part of
frank and i
are together it's just not on an
intimate level
right so frank and i vacationed together
and frank and i raised our children
together and the divorce
didn't mean that that was going to be
the end of our relationship
it's just like just being with your best
friend
and having that best friend that
business partner that
co-parent in your life for the rest of
your life
so there's is there any shot in hell
that ever happens
no did me and frank sleep with each
other no
he just left and he just called me
that's what the interruption was
he just called me and you know every
time
like i send him a picture of my new
plastic surgery he's like
what good is that doing me
[Laughter]
i mean the lines are a little muddied
but it feels like they've always been
muddied just the life you've built
the life i've built works for me and
it's been very hard and i hope i'm an
inspiration to other people
not to let peer pressure not to let what
people
think you should be doing in your life
to find you
because at the end of the day somebody
once told me you have to live with your
own decisions
at the end of the day before you put
your head on that pillow you are the one
you walk in your own
shoes you live with the decisions you've
made so don't ever let anybody sway you
the way you they think you should go
[Music]